e
good
morning I'll call the fiscal committee
meeting to order for the August 16th
2024 meeting and the first item is the
acceptance of minutes of June 20th so
move second and July 10th both of those
take that as both of them is there any
who was that second it was Senator
Bradley and Senator
gray um any any omissions or or
Corrections seeing none all in favor of
accepting the minutes for those two
dates June 20th and J July 10th say I I
any opposed say
no and I want to welcome Senator sus
replacing Senator rosenal to the
business and under tab first tab three
is where the U consent calendar goes
from tabs 3 through n in the house pre
fiscal meetings we we have listed
several bills that we want removed to
question uh on the consent calendar I
will read them now under tab
three
252 and
six
258 and
241 and under Tab
272 there are a few left on the consent
calendar I'll entertain a motion to
adopt the rest of the consent calendar
Senator Bradley moves Senator alesandro
seconds to adopt the rest of the consent
calendar all in favor say I I oppe
nay that rest of the consent calendar is
adopted first item will come to for
Education welcome commissioner good
morning and for the record Frank D blue
Commissioner of Education
Tammy Valen cour CFO for the
Department
okay
um it was curious why even though you're
already occupying the
building and you're in the building so
much more money has to be spent now for
modifications so that was that was a
curious thing we all wondered about yeah
so great question and I appreciate that
question what's not completely clear
from the fiscal item and I apologize for
that is uh the original purchase uh
negotiated price based upon an appr
appraisal with $7 million for this
facility um in a typical real estate
transaction there are is an inspection
done and there is a list of items that
need to be uh you know mitigated um so
the actual purchase price for this
building was not the $7 million it was
actually $6,250 so a $750,000 decrease
off of the capital appropriation um and
so working with Das they had asked us to
look at otherwise lapsing General funds
from the previous fiscal year to be able
to bring forward uh to be able to
mitigate some of those punch list items
as part of the close uh the types of
items that that's going to include our
various you know repair and maintenance
uh types of things in the building which
would be expected um I still think you
know I was thinking about this as I was
coming today I still think we have
actually got quite a good deal um I you
know in terms of the the value six
$250,000 I believe that the estimates of
the repair of the facility that we
previously were in are near know 10 to
15 million of continuing investment in
that building so um the facility is
actually working out quite nicely uh
it's proximate location to the highway
is very convenient to Educators we have
over
7,000 uh you know outside visitors to
the agency every year um it includes uh
an event space and some classrooms so
were able to conduct continuing uh
education for educators just yesterday
we had um you know a training session
going on in several of our classrooms
for Discovery Education and and bringing
Educators in so uh we're happy with the
facility very good and this is how far
from your present position where over in
the office Park how far yeah uh it's
just a couple of Miles um but it is
actually tends to be a little bit more
convenient in the sense that it's right
on Main Street and right off of the
highway so again all these external
visitors that stop by it's very easy for
them to find us right off of the highway
and convenient for them to get in and
out I guess I'm not familiar with allall
street so it's it's the grand State
College building the old Grand State
College building right off of 93 yep now
I know where it is thank you further
questions from committee members
representative Lehman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so you say that there won't be
really any impact on existing programs
by taking more than a half a million
dollars from that line could you explain
that that it's a lot of money and that
the removal won't impact so these are
funds that we would have been lapsing
from last year that are then carrying
forward so uh essentially rather than
using the Capital Savings because we
procured It For Less I think Das wanted
to just basically use these laps funds
to be able to do those uh repairs on the
building okay thanks thank you Mr
chairman okay I'll entertain a motion to
uh adopt the item move to approve second
motion by Senator gray second by Senator
Bradley to approve the item further
discussions seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no sounds like you got a good
[Music]
and representa Edwards had a comment or
was it represent was it Lehman me was
you representative Earth is
recognized let them introduce themselves
first let them introduce themselves
first
yes welcome Mr White good morning I'm
Kaa Fox I'm the director of the division
for Behavioral Health at
HHS good morning Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services
good morning and thank you both for
being here I I don't have a question but
I want to explain why I'm going to
oppose this um first of all I really
appreciate uh Mr White's uh explanation
it it was excellent the concern I have
though is we're adding five new general
General funded positions General funds
funded positions and I think we've made
clear the last couple B budget cycles
that we're not looking to grow headcount
um in the
department and think this is becoming um
more relevant in light of the fact that
uh next year next cycle excuse me we can
expect um a tighter budget cycle for a
variety of reasons one of which of
course is we increased Medicaid rates
and those are really going to hit um
next budget cycle the other is all the
co and arpa funds are expiring and I
don't know because we're not it doesn't
get reported to us how many of those are
actually used for um ongoing expenses
which will probably want to be um uh
continued so for those reasons um I I
feel that even with Mr White's
explanation if it was such a high
priority uh goal to have these five new
positions that would make sense to just
reallocate um your current Personnel to
thank you for the um question uh comment
representative f um during the last
budget cycle in House Bill 2 we we had
one of the questions that was posed that
I just kind of want to address for the
committee um uh offline prior to the
meeting was you know what what services
are you stopping um and no Services were
being stopped here the funds that are
being used here were appropriated to us
via
hb2 um they they were funds that were
repurposed from a prior bium um and
there was there was a broad uh Authority
relative to the use of those funds and
needs have been identified to support
the the current and ongoing initiatives
uh where we have not had adequate staff
capacity and c I don't know if you want
to comment on that sure um as you have
very much um been involved in the
infusion of dollars um as we look at new
programming and expanded programming to
address the needs of people in New
Hampshire uh for mental health and
substance use services and with that
funding comes additional responsibility
on the department and to be good
stewards of those dollars we need to
make sure that they're being spent
efficiently and effectively and we have
seen this amazing growth um as the needs
um have have uh required um but we have
not grown the people um and the staff to
be able to continue that oversight and
today further discussion on the
item Senator dallis Sandra uh thank you
Mr chman first of all thanks very much
for coming always good to see you K good
to see
you as as uh referencing representative
her questions where where are we as we
begin to prepare for the next badium
with regard to this situation this is
got to be an ongoing situation we got to
we have services that we have to render
and uh where are we as we're pling for
the future sure um our department as
well as every other agency in the state
we were given our budget Targets on
August 1st um we are currently in the
process of going through and looking at
every class line looking at every need
and trying to um
prioritize those things that need to be
absolutely 100% need to be within our
efficiency budget as well as those items
that uh would be included as prioritized
needs so uh we're very much in the
throws of that right now um our agency
budget will be completed uh midt and
submitted to the Department
administrative services and published on
the 1st of
October thank you but but if I could
thank you but but indeed given given the
uh the meble with regard to the budget
you you're going to establish priorities
obviously as As you move
forward but with programs like this that
you're you're driving
forward uh they've got to be sustained
or maintained and I think that in for my
vision I'm not going to be here for the
prepar ation of the budget I'm sorry
you're going to miss me we will but but
I think uh a lot of consideration has to
be given by by this group I think as to
what's going to happen move moving
forward because we're making these
commitments here uh you know based on
existing funds so I I think we're okay
for for for
25 I think we're going to survive 25
okay but I'm very concerned very
concerned about the future very
concerned so uh I think you I think you
have your I think you have your hands
full in meeting the obligations that
you're you're committed to here and also
going
forward thank you I appreciate your
Edwards what do you want me to do is
there a response to that um as I said
before at this point in time we're we're
looking at all of our programming and
all of our costs and looking at things
globally and at a micro level and um we
haven't made any decisions yet but those
will be reflected in the coming weeks in
our budget and I agree with your
commentary yes it will be challenging it
challenging representative thank thank
you Mr chair uh and and thank you for uh
taking the question this is this is more
a a strategic overview question we have
tried in the last two budget Cycles to
uh be very aggressive at funding it
Investments for infrastructure and and
one of our um thoughts driving that has
been to give the department the
productivity tools it needs to have in
order to uh continue to redeploy
Manpower to the highest value uh tasks
and and I've I've heard you read your
email and it's a great email like
representative Earth said and I've heard
your answer I I just I'm just wondering
to what extent uh do you and and we can
take most of this answer offline but I'm
just curious are are we starting to see
the impact of the money that we've spent
the last two budget Cycles on it in
terms of productivity
improvements and are they are they
discernable are they
describable sure so um I I think Dave
weeders our our chief operating officer
would be uh most qualified to answer
that question but in this past budget
there were two Appropriations in hb2
specifically for it Consultants one to
help us with the design and two to help
us with implementation and there has
been ongoing work across the department
to implement Salesforce based Solutions
as well as some other e signature and
and uh expedited processing but um yes
we have seen improvements in that but I
think what's important to recognize is
that that's not necessarily going to
eliminate the need for positions I think
with every legislative cycle uh both at
the state and federal level we continue
to have additional reporting
requirements additional programming
requirements put on the department that
continues to take away the resources
that we have so while I do think that
efficiencies are incredibly important to
gain through those I just want to also
recognize the fact
that the the Baseline operating needs
well absolutely agree government's
growing we're asking more and more of
you absolutely agree with your point I I
I'd like to just keep this other point
distinct though are are we seeing uh
payback in terms of increased
productivity as a result of the it
infrastructure Investments sure would it
would it be acceptable if I had um d
weers uh follow up with some detail
specific details on the various uh
programs that have been implemented
would that be helpful right right and
and and if you just because we're in a
budget cycle it's going to be a big
question next year particularly so we
don't need an immediate answer but it's
excellent
proof excuse
me on item
24252 Senator gray moves to approve
senator Bradley seconds Is there further
discussion seeing none those in favor
say I I oppose no no no two two nose um
the rest are eyes so you wish to be
recorded there's
nose all
right moving on
to tab
six oh still in 3 still on no we still
Services
talking mathematics
here I read the item it says approval of
1,838
351 when I look at the item I don't see
that figure
repeated and we were trying to figure
out how that figure came to be and took
some rather imaginative moving figures
around to come up with it is that in
7659 that is a great question for the
record Sherry Rockburn uh assistant
commissioner Department administrative
Services um I'll have to take a take a
look at the difference um I didn't
notice a math error when I we were
reviewing it so I'll have to take a look
to see what that variance is normally
it's the combination of um both
accounting units so there's a
combination of 444 and the 72,000 that's
getting moved within the accounts um so
I'll have to I can get you a detail
sheet of sort of exactly how that comes
up I think what's throwing it is that we
have a both the ins and outs of 1.3
million that's coming out of one accy
unit and there's uh significant numbers
of coming into the accounting unit so
I'll have to look at the math for you to
break that out I know we did look at
that but I'll take a look at it give us
a wave when you got your figures done
yep sir just give me a few minutes and
I'll take a look sure we'll uh Skip by
it for
now and we'll go on to tab
and I believe it was representative
Edwards had questions on these are
incentive payments and yes sir do we
want D yeah we'll we new folks introduce
yourselves good morning I'm David chy
the deputy Medicaid director I'm here
for Henry
Litman and welcome back Mr White
CFO um so so this question is um I'm I'm
I'm fine with the proposal I I just have
uh some questions as I understand the
the process and and I I need you to
correct me if I'm mistaken is is that we
withhold 2% of the premium payments to
Medicaid M the
mcos so that we can create some
incentive goals some stretch goals for
them to achieve that further uh State uh
policies and priorities and to the
extent that they hit those get paid
those on a on a timely basis but any
money that's not spent out to pay for um
an incentive payment gets with with
withheld and stored until the sometime
after the accounting period of the
contract closes and all of that money
that's withheld still needs to go back
to the mcos is is that
correct yes okay so with that in place m
my questions are um do the
mcos know how to book any anticipated
Revenue that may come back to them
through the payment of the unpaid out
incentive programs in other words do
they have an accounting concern if they
don't have enough data to adequately
know I I don't
know but they do know the total
capitation amount um and the the total
amount of funds available and what's
been earned up to a period of time and
what's left over um and they would be
able to account um I think on their
books and and I I think the challenge
that they have and and I'm not in the
weeds but and you are but I think the
problem that they have is that there is
they know the pool but they know that
there are three mcos and they don't know
the meth methodology in which you will
carve up the remaining un unspent
balance and as a result of not knowing
the methodology you will use to um to
make a proportionate payout they are uh
hesitant to book An accounts receivable
does that does that and I I I I I maybe
maybe you could just take that away and
think about it and and talk to the mcos
about it um uh and then I may I follow
up follow up
um now I I I'm I'm a big believer in
stretch goals and but there seems to be
two things at play when we do stretch
goals or incentive goals is that U there
needs to be some hope that the stretch
goals are
achievable um we don't want to create a
stretch goal that we know or or should
know is really not achievable um and and
you know sort of mess with them without
any chance of success that's one thing
the other thing is some of these stretch
goals will would need to be in place for
one two three years to let the these
kind of Battleship
mcos move towards where we're directing
so in your opinion do you think we are
coming up with uh
adequately uh stretched goals not
overstretched and do you think we're
leaving them in place long enough to
become achievable
I do so we do look at
um the the you know the likelihood that
the MCO could potentially reach the goal
without making it too easy but also
without making it too hard um and for
certain goals you know we want to see
you know A continuing Trend over because
it's a five-year contract over over a
period of time um so when you look at
the current contract that we're about to
go live with on September first one of
the goals is the new Primary Care Focus
model um and health risk ass assessment
completion and so that would sort of be
a a ramp up of like in year one we would
like to see this and that we would
likely keep that metric in future years
seeing continued growth um similar with
lead
screening um but then there are also
more short-term goals um that we want to
incentivize the mcos with um for example
in the unwind we wanted the MOs to help
with Outreach and redetermination so
that was more of a a focused um shorter
term goal because the the unwind had an
end end start a definitive star and end
date um or we somewhat
definitive um so so thank you Mr chair
thank you for the answer um and then uh
I'd like to move to pass this if there's
no other discussion all right motion to
approve is is there a second second by
Senator Susi further discussion seeing
none uh motion was to approve
24256 is there any U are you ready for
the question all in favor say I oppose
nay that item is adopted please stay
seated we'll be right with you in a
minute I'm just going to announce that
257 has
been removed and we're moving on to
and this was another
one that speaks about dish payments you
may want to bring another on I have a
question Mr chair on Senator gay since
we didn't talk about
257 um uh before we took the vote to
pass all the other items on the consent
calendar um it may be wise to have a
motion for
reconsideration on that motion and then
pull it and then have the vote again but
I'm looking towards uh
legislative sure um so 257 was withdrawn
by the department the letter itself is
the necessary action to remove that so
um no additional once that letter is
submitted the item is no longer under
consideration so no additional motions
are necessary okay thank you okay okay
now we come to U
24258 dealing with Dish
payments and I believe somebody had a
question about the state plan Amendment
uh representative Edwards yes sir thank
you so um you I'm sure you recall that
at the end of this uh legislative
session there was a lot of discussion in
the legislature about whether or not the
dish payments should be paid out to the
hospitals uh at a 91% or maybe a 93% or
somewhere in between and and the
legislature failed to agree to anything
in the committee of conference and
therefore the governor uh has stated
publicly that um he's going to uh
uh distribute 80%
uh with the idea of keeping the other
20% for other community services and so
that was the last I had heard about this
was back in early early July I'm just
wondering if there's any update that you
could give us relative to what we're
doing with the disproportionate share
distributions
uh good morning David chy again Deputy
Medicaid director um so uh we are
following through with the 80% plan we
don't really have an update um on the
80% plan right now but with respect to
New Hampshire hospital and Dish payments
under the prior met settlement agreement
and the um prior State Statute uh New
Hampshire hospital is not included in
the The Met dish settlement so for
purposes of the 91% or 80% calculating
it
um any of the funds New Hampshire
hospital pays outside of that um and
that's because under federal law there's
a separate allotment for imds which is
New Hampshire hospital um and so there's
that anything further I I I don't have
any further
questions Senator Dall Sandra thank you
Mr
chair just for point of clarification
the dish deal is in the deal that we had
is in place they've already paid the be
they should have been reimbursed for
this year it's the New Deal that
begins is that isn't that correct so the
80% we asked for a change in the plan
and so forth but that's for the future
right correct I want it to be clear that
the hospitals got 91% back because that
Arrangement was in place and it had it
was in existence and A Change Is for for
for the next Val so uh that has to be
dealt with by the
legislature uh because the current deal
expired right and so so they got the 91%
back at at this point in time it's for
the future uh that that this 80%
situation will be discussed by the
legisl governor has one idea but I think
the legislature has has an option to
work on that and and to make its own
decision
with regard to that I I I I find that uh
this situation this 80%
nonsense have been done
uh Fiat
that's that's in my opinion not the way
to not the way to do business this
legislature should have a say in that we
all have hospitals in our districts
we're all being serviced by those
hospitals those hospitals uh are
performing and we had a we had an
arrangement that was in place for a
period of years that uh we thought was
failly successful I think the hospitals
did too so this change that's going to
take place going to have to be dealt
correct yes thank you I love those quick
answers I love yes I hate
no thank you so so if I may Senator I
want to give you some more yes I agree
with everything you just said I wanted
to understand what the status was
several months later because we're R in
the we're running out of time in the
house to submit legislation and I just
want to let the the Senators know that
if if if there's a bill to be worked on
in this area I'm open to doing that but
my clock is ticking right appreciate
that thank you for that Cod but I I
think I mean I'm not going to be here
but I think the Senate will have
something to say I would hope
so thank you
is there a motion on the item 258
24258 moved by Senator Bradley second by
Senator dallis Andro is there any
further discussion seeing none you ready
for the question all in favor say I
oppose no that item is adopted before we
go to Sher Rockburn again we'll finish
up this uh
refugees and the question
arose you obviously
list 210 Afghans and 923
ukrainians how many others from other
countries are are we uh taken care of
other than those that are
listed do we know do we know what other
groups that we might
have good morning an landre associate
commissioner thank you for the question
so um yes we have estimates of what is
anticipated what the state has approved
for the upcoming year sorry my phone
just went um and
so sorry where did that just
go Um the best estimate um for the
upcoming year is 315 refugees that are
coming from countries outside of Ukraine
and Afghanistan or Cuba or haa those are
um special kind of refugee
categories so the standard Refugee
resettlement program that we're
anticipating for the upcoming Federal
fiscal year is
3155 and these are all covered with
federal funds yes this is a Fed fully
federally funded program across the
country um and the state the federal
government works um with each state and
allocating um the number of refugees we
you representative Earth Do you happen
to know how many of these programs that
are letting these quote refugees in are
the result of executive orders as
law in the executive order you're
referring to like the ukrainians and
Afghanistan those emergency humanitarian
or no specifically with the 315 others
that you're referring to the others no I
don't know which ones are related to
executive order there's there they
anticipate a number of refugees from
certain com um countries each year right
that are dealing with civil wars or
religious persecution or what have you
and I'm not sure which ones are related
to executive order or not okay thank
right representative Edwards uh uh thank
you um and thank you Miss Landry for
taking the question uh I I I think I
think just to sort of restate where I I
I I believe State policy is on this and
uh and hope that you all are executing
it when no one's around is that is that
um uh we understand the refugee program
we understand the federal money that's
coming to it and there and so there are
questions around whether or not the
federal funds are adequate if they cease
to become adequate we we should be
getting a heads up that the the money
isn't keeping up with the the the
federal obligation that's one thing and
then the second thing is uh there are
other categories other than refugees uh
there are I don't think Asylum Seekers
count as refugees and certainly the Goda
ways don't count um as as either Asylum
Seekers or refugees uh are are we making
explicit um Endeavors to ensure that uh
Goda ways are not receiving state
benefits other than those mandated to
ERS what what's the status of our in our
making sure the Integrity of of the
eligibility I guess yes thank you so I
can't speak to how emergency rooms
across the state serve any population
right that's that's up I mean there's
the they serve whomever comes into their
emergency room but that is completely
separate from our Refugee resettlement
program in which we have Federal Refugee
resettlement agencies that are um part
of the nine I think it's eight or nine
federal resettlement agencies that have
local branches and the only the only
individuals who are served by the
federal funds that come through this
program are those legal refugees that
the federal government says they're
ready for New Hampshire it does there
are C there are you're right you know
humanitary PE that's where the Ukrainian
status is or all there are ases there
are special immigrant visas they're all
part of the federal Refugee resettlement
program and some of those categories
receive like these cash of medical and
some do not it just depends on the
status but the only individuals for
which this program serves are the legal
Refugee refugees that come through this
program so there it's very much vetted
it's there's lots of federal reporting
there's no discrepancy of of what the
these dollars are for they only serve
those refugees that come through the
program and and and did you say that the
federal funding so far has been adequate
to the task oh I apologize to your first
question yes as far as we know that in
fact we've had um they've increased the
amount of funding in the last couple
years due to the Afghan population that
has arrived as well as ukrainians that
continue to arrive so there has been
more than adequate funding to to serve
this population
thank you Mr chair if there aren't any
other questions I'd move to approve
second motion by representative Edward
second by Senator asso to approve item
24270 is there any further discussion
seeing none all in favor say I I oppose
no that that is adopted I'd like to now
three and call on Sher Rockburn
thank you I apologize for not having the
math uh in my head a little bit sooner
so there's three numbers that make this
up the first if you look at the very
first page the transfers out of
444,000 plus the
72,000 those two numbers total 51
7444 in addition to that there's another
transfer out of 1 million
32097 it's on page two and it's line um
022 so on page two of the 1.3 million
plus the 500 and 17,000 those numbers
make up 1 18 38 351 that's in the
total so I'll give you a minute to take
a look at that but the the total that's
always written in the letter is the sum
of the transfers out even though there's
ins and outs that sort of would offset
it we just focus on the all the negative
numbers which are the transfers out and
those will that 1838 351 which is
correctly stated in the requested
action thank you all right so the figure
is correct but it's just not spelled out
in a way that's easily recognized and we
can make that change on future one so
it's a little bit more clear appreciate
it uh any further discussions on item
24264 second Senator gray moves the Adam
Senator Bradley second any further
discussion seeing none you ready for the
question all in favor favor say I oppose
no the item is adopted thank you for the
seven and we had item 241 the only item
I had a question it it talked about
giving these
um to communities that were low and
moderate communities where do I find a
list of who's a low low and who's a
moderate
Community good morning Mr chairman for
the record Josh Elliot director of the
division of policy and programs with the
New Hampshire Department of energy um
that is an excellent question so US EPA
um who is granting us these funds has
divised has just excuse me defined low
moderate income is the household making
less than 80% of area median income or
less um across the state So that
obviously varies by County um that
aligns with um Housing and Urban
development's um threshold for living in
subsidized housing for example oh it's
by county and if you're
lowincome you're only making 80% of the
average income in that county correct
okay and then that is is then controlled
for um by household size as well thank
you I was curious about that and where
would I go to look at up where that
figure might
be is it under the EPA or is it some
under the census or um I can I'd be
happy to provide the committee uh with
the list where it has the breakout of
everywhere in the state for those
figures appreciate it thank you because
we're all wondering if Okay can my
communities qualify well are they low
are they moderate what are they if if I
may follow up it's not necessarily the
community itself it's the individuals
who meet that criteria so you could have
for example a very wealthy community
where somebody happens to be making 80%
or less of area median income in that
Community they would qualify so there's
no restriction in terms of where the
person lives or where the household
lives anybody who meets those criterias
would be would be eligible to benefit
all right so it's an individual that
gets the grant not the not a community
system well it would be a um the the
individual or the household that
qualifies would be able to receive the
benefits from the installation of these
arrays the arrays themselves would be
installed um depending on how where they
come in the door so to speak um either
by uh grants provided by the Community
Loan Fund uh the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority or the uh through a
grant through the department itself
thank you further discussions on the
item all right questions have been
answered anybody wish to approve
so
moved all right Senator Bradley moves
approval Senator dallesandro seconds for
24241 are there any further discussion
seeing none all you're ready for the
question all in favor say I I oppose no
that item is
adopted okay moving on to tab
eight last one we have a question
and you will introduce
yourself good morning miles Greenway
yes represent lean for a question thank
you Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question so there has been some
notoriety about this activity recently
and I did hear from representative groda
from Ry um looking for a commitment and
transparency and more public
participation which I guess maybe
over uh thanks for the question so we uh
did address a little bit of that on the
8th at at our last PDA board meeting um
of this month uh also I'm working hand
inand and letting the planning board
know for Ry uh what's happening keeping
them in contact with everyone and we're
going to um we're in the process right
now of having a couple of more public
meetings um not in between now and the
next board meeting as well well so um
they're just trying to be as transparent
as possible as well as with the other uh
project that's in Portsmith to for the
commercial fishing
pier okay I guess that's all I have Mr
chairman thank you thank you uh
discussions with the previous director
were about retail on on the Ry Ry Harbor
and he and thank you for the photos you
sent us it looked like parking would be
a problem and I remember he he EXP
express that to me that you know that
you couldn't have retail there and still
have parking for the fisherman and the L
fill up the parking lot and take their
boats out and may not be any space left
for retail so wonder how we're dealing
with that is there a project in mind you
going to enlarge the whole Space you
going to make more parking or what thank
you thanks for the question sir so right
now the commercial fisherman park over
on the commercial Pier side uh haven't
had any complaints about parking uh so
far or but but you are correct if we
move forward with the proposed plans it
would uh incorporate a little bit of the
parking that we use right now for the
recreational side and commerci and
recreational fishing and those folks
that are attending for the
establishments there so we're still
working with uh the engineers and our
staff to work through that with the
parking thank you further questions on
the
item to approve sing none motion to
approve 242 72 by Senator gray second by
Senator Bradley further discussion
seeing none you ready for the question
all in favor say I I oppose
no okay we're done with the consent
calendar under tab nine I think tab yeah
Tab
10 all
right first item is Youth Development
Center claims Administration and
settlement
fund and you can you can sit on those
chairs over there if you got other
people that want to have input if
there's not enough room for them at the
table Yeah you can sit thank you Mr
chair sit on the end there and and and
if you speak remember to push the button
microphone General felo
welcome thank you Mr chair members of
the committee uh for the record John
fella attorney general and joining me
today to my right is Attorney Laura
Raymond in the Civil Bureau at the
Attorney General's office she has
replaced uh Jen Ramsey as the AG design
for the YDC claims process so she's been
spearheading our efforts there we're
also joined this morning by Jen Foley
she is general counsel with the
administrator's office Matt Broadhead
associate attorney general in in our
office head of the division of legal
councel and Tom Kemper who is the
director of claims at operations for for
the YDC claims process in the office so
we know this is an important item and we
wanted to make sure everyone who
potentially might need to speak to it is
here um I'm going
to if if it would be helpful in a minut
I'll turn it over to to attorney Raymond
to give you an overview but I'll just
start by sort of setting the context
here we're here today to get approval to
the revisions to the guidelines and the
other documents for the YDC claims
process these revisions are are really
just meant to implement the revisions
that we just made with in this past
legislative session so as you'll recall
we had extensive negotiations with with
clayman's Council um to come up with
revisions to to the YDC claims process
that would result in the vast majority
of the claimants coming through the
process as opposed to going through
litigation so that bill passed in the
last session after the bill was signed
by the governor in June we we've had a
lot of discussions with clayman's
Council since then to come up with the
revisions or these revisions to the
guidelines and you will have received a
letter from Nix and pebody and and and
Riley and Associates that indicates that
they are I would say supportive of these
revisions I don't want I don't have the
letter in front of me but I I think what
they said is with these revisions while
there was negotiation and they didn't
get everything they wanted we didn't get
everything we wanted this was a
sufficient compromise for them to
continue to feel that they could
recommend this process to the vast
majority of their clients um so that
that is the product you see before you I
certainly want to thank Nick and pebody
and Riley and Associates and and all the
attorneys involved there and all the
other claimant Council for coming to the
table and engaging in these negotiations
I want to thank everyone who's here
today with me for for the work on this
the work that's been done so far and and
the work to come uh with that I'm going
to turn it over to to attorney Raymond
just to give you an overview of the
biggest pieces of these revisions and
then I'll certainly be here to answer
questions as well but Laura spearheaded
the the details of this so I want to
give her a chance to to give you that
overview for discussion purposes the
committee we're looking at both 261 and
262 which are very closely related so if
you have questions on either one this is
the the moment but go ahead and give us
the
explanation thank you and good morning
um so I would be happy to walk through
um in the order of our item the um sort
of overview of what the proposed
revision to these documents are we've
also provided to the committee today um
a handout a one-page handout that
summarizes those changes to both the
guidelines governing um the value of
claims as well as the process believe
those were just handed out to hopefully
guide um this overview as well just back
up from the mic about an inch or two
sorry about
that thank you so uh first with respect
to the uh claims process
as attorney general for Mela mentioned
uh the main driver of the proposed
revisions there was the changes to the
statute that passed in this most recent
legislative session so the changes there
are really focused on updating some
timelines um to bring the claims process
as it previously existed in line with
those new amendments um another
significant procedural change outlined
on your handout uh is the fact that the
claims administrator now has the
discretion under the statute to
determine whether to award uh payments
from the fund in a lump sum or in
installment payments over time that is a
change from the uh previous practice
where the claimant uh had the discretion
to make that election so that is also
reflected in the changes um to the
process that will help I think ensure um
the stability and solvency of the fund
over time for many more claims to come
uh we also um again in looking at those
um time frames we're looking to expedite
certain parts of the claim process to
that end um the process also now allows
for um brief oral arguments by council
at the end of a resolution proceeding
again a change to the previous process
one that I um we've sort of been beta
testing uh for lack of a better word in
resolution proceedings and I think is
going well so far and will ultimately
in an expedited process of uh Awards
being issued uh after follow following a
resolution proceeding um and finally uh
the new statute as amended provides that
instead of submitting a complete Claim
by the deadline of June 30th 2025
claimants can instead submit a notice of
claim form that is included with the
item for approval today and when a
claimant submits that form um they are
essentially putting the fund on notice
that they intend to submit a claim but
maybe don't have all of their complete
materials right now and they have 60
days following the submission of that
form to submit a completed claim um so
that's also a change from the current
process so in lie of filing a full
complete Claim by June 30th 2025 they
can also file a notice of Claim by that
date and still be extended 60 days to
file their complete claim those are sort
of a high level um overview of the
changes to the process I would be happy
to answer any questions about that
specifically or continue through to the
guidelines
themselves senator dallesandro for a
question thank you thank you thank you
very
much stuff you said this was was fine
thank you I did get the letter from the
lawyers and it seems to me that there in
there in concurrence with the changes
that have been made u i I would like to
know the number of people who have filed
claims this number has been bounced
around I I think in the letter they
talked about 1,00 somebody said about 15
how many claims have been filed what is
the number of claims that we're dealing
with at this time yes so that number as
642 um Miss uh Foley or Tom may have an
updated number it's 632 okay 632 and
that's just to clarify that's claims in
the claims process were you asking
Senator about that and also about
lawsuits filed or just claims in the
claims process the number of the number
of individual who are involved in in the
in the legal aspects of this this is
lawsuits in your administrative work yep
I I I think lawsuits it's it's 13 to
14400 at this point I I don't have that
exact number on top of my head so so
that's that's a realistic number that
that's I've heard that a a variety of
numbers I'd like to focus on what the
real number
is U as as I think the public should be
aware of that obviously when you look at
that and when you look at what's
happened in terms of the settlements you
got X number of dollars that are out the
door you're expecting you know an
additional appropriation that that's
going to come I think we should have at
least anide idea of how many cases we're
dealing with I I think Senator when we
get to June 30th 2025 that will be the
point where we get the final number of
of claims that will come through this
process um you know we we can we can
make a projection of what we think it
will be but you know we we won't know
the final number until then but but I
think the
projection is extremely important
because that projection is going to call
for
appropriation yep and some somebody
around this St was going to have to make
that
appropriation yes well and that that
gets to and this isn't necessarily part
of the the guidelines and the process
today but that that gets to you know the
payment well the payments over time are
part of the process but then the $75
million cap per per fiscal year so so
yes we when we were going through the
legislative process we discussed the
fact that the sooner we have the
deadline for
the window to close the sooner we will
finally be able to say this is how many
claims came into the process this was
the total amount claimed and we you know
based we've resolved about 200 claims
now and the average award has been
maintaining around
$500,000 so I think once we get the
total number of claims in and we know
that's that's it we'll be able to make a
projection sort of over how many years
we're going to need to continue funding
this given the cap of $75 million per
year thank you thank you Mr
CH representative Lehman for a question
thank you Mr chairman I I had a few but
I'll certainly go through the chair on
page 12 there's a mention of a a maximum
of three
hours for the discussion of a
claim what happens if it has to go over
3 hours this is just a suggested
guideline or or is this in fact that 3
hours hour the gabble comes down and
that's
it in my experience um with resolution
proceedings and and and having attended
them and having uh gotten information
about each one that has occurred
actually none have come close to 3 hours
that's because it's I you know it's it's
a very difficult conversation for the
claimant um the victim to have and it's
not the intent I think of anyone in this
process either from our office or from
the administrator's office to continue
to sort of compound that by dragging it
on for the full 3 hours they often don't
go that long I imagine if it had to No
One Would object to a continuation of
additional
time a further question further question
I think it was on page 22 in
my notes here
um the payment out over time I think is
up to 10 years is that something you've
tried to get already or people willing
so I can speak to that um we are
starting to implement the considerations
for that uh the claimants that I have
seen information on so far um none
have uh affirmatively expressed a a
willingness to go for a full 10 years
but many have expressed a willingness to
do some sort of of payment plan that
being said the discretion to award that
payment plan is vested in the
administrator considering the claimant's
financial circumstances um and the other
uh items delineated uh in the statute
such as health and things like that um
but it is remains fested in the
administrator
regardless one and I would I would just
add that we're in very early days for
for the new sort of the new provision
that that allows the administrator to
meet
to award these or make these Awards and
installments so I think we'll be we'll
be better place to to give you feedback
on that in in the months
ahead one final question if I could Mr
chairman thank you I know we're all
sickened by what happened you know here
over the decades and I looked at like
the guidelines for the payouts for
particular types of assault where did
those guidelines I know we've talked
about this in the past and I think some
suggestion was made out the states were
looked at are these new Baseline award
amounts are these new numbers that
you've come up with or are they based on
past so I can uh speak with respect to
the new uh award values that were
assigned uh in the guidelines themselves
which is um the next document up on uh
the discussion um so for those um dollar
amounts we did do um some research
search into things like what uh claims
for similar type of conduct have settled
for um in other states within this state
um and tried to you know develop a a
baseline uh award amount that seemed
appropriate in light of um the conduct
being alleged versus the conduct uh in
the remainder of the guidelines the
dollar values for which had already been
approved by the committee so it was sort
of trying to uh you know place it in
that Matrix which already existed um
considering a wide range of factors
including um you know how often it
occurred the severity um all of those
factors were considerations and in fact
those dollar Figures were part of um
what was open to negotiation with
claimant's Council and we did have many
conversations both with the Nix imp PE
Law Firm about those values and what
would be appropriate as well as Council
for other claimants too so that was
achieved with a a broad measure of
consensus I would say thank you thank
you Mr
chairman other
members Senator Susi thank you Mr
chairman just one if I may I just wanted
to clarify the 632 number is all
inclusive so some of those may be
withdrawn or
deemed not worthy of following through
the process so 632 is everything
presented that's true and some some have
been resolved by now as well great thank
you uh without any additional questions
on the process I would be happy to turn
more fully to the guidelines um we've uh
just begun discussing them but again
just to uh give you an overview of the
major proposed changes to those
documents um the first was to address
the new categories of abuse um added by
the legislature in the most recent
amendments specific Al uh those were
unlawful restraint um both isolated
confinement and placement in physical
mechanical or pharmaceutical restraints
both of those are uh defined as unlawful
restraint under the new statute uh also
unlawful strip search intentional
infliction of emotional distress
Reckless conduct criminal threatening
and invasion of privacy so we slotted
all of those new categories of
compensable abuse into the existing
framework of the guidelin lines um per
the the Mandate in the new statute
there's also a mandate in that uh
amended statute to provide compensation
for egregious sexual abuse so we um
included that definition in the
guidelines as well and explained the
standard for compensation there uh
finally the other major change um was
just to update the aggravating factors
that are found near the end of the
guidelines that can increase uh an award
if certain things take place the statute
um added a couple new categories of AG
aggravating factors um mainly a greater
impact of the abuse on the claimant as
compared to others similarly situated um
subjection to multiple forms of um
sexual and other abuse
simultaneously and participation by more
um than one actor physically in an act
of sexual or other abuse so those were
the main changes to those guidelines
there
um again would be happy to uh take any
additional questions from the committee
members about
those I think you really open the door
or at least the legislature did by
adding this other and including solitary
confinement this opens the door for the
SEC the secure housing unit in the
prison where all of the people there are
in solitary confinement 23 hours a day
if we think that's
compensable through a lawsuit we're
really in trouble all those people could
go and get these same lawyers and come
back and sue us saying oh I I was really
tortured by the four years I spent in
solitary confinement this this really
opens the door and another thing that
disturbs me and it supposedly is left
left to the attorney general is why we
don't more widely use lie
detectors um my friends in La
enforcement really put a lot of faith in
them and you might eliminate a whole
bunch of these people if they couldn't
pass a lie detector test and that would
be a lot quicker than the three hours
that you're going to might spend on all
these questions on all the people
involved it seems like it ought to
be an automatic review that everybody
goes through this I and supposedly it's
left to your authority to do this and I
wonder why you haven't asked for
it so I'll respond to both of those
points Mr chair the first just to just
sort of opening the door to solitary
confinement or intentional Affliction of
emotional distress and other
incarceration settings like like the
prison I I just point out a couple
things one you know this this is you
what we're talking about here the cases
we're talking about here are unique
because when these things occurred these
individuals were were kids so kid yes
they were in a Juvenile Detention
Facility but but they were kids for whom
you know the state was not we weren't
just the intention was not just to lock
them up but also to to rehabilitate them
to to get them Services get get them
treatment so I I would point out that
first
second the the compensable solitary
confinement for purposes of this process
it's only compensable if there's there
wasn't some legitimate basis or or
reason or it was or um it's only
compensable if it was excessive so it's
not to say that any time someone might
have been placed in solitary confinement
that would be compensable it's if there
wasn't I mean I'm paraphrasing so so um
so I want to be a little careful but
basically it it has to be that there
there wasn't a legitimate basis or some
some other some other good reason for
for the solitary confinement um to your
point on the lie detector test I mean it
it
really that is just part of the overall
consideration of this process um in in
balancing the the need to you know have
some level of verification and
investigation of these claims with with
the need to um recognize that we're
talking about individuals who who who
were victims of physical and sexual
abuse when when they were children we
certainly would never if someone came to
law enforcement and said that they had
been abused as a child I mean not even
as an adult but as a child we certainly
would not put them through a lie
detector test it's just not how we how
we treat victims of of sexual abuse
especially but we we absolutely would
not do that if we're talking about child
victims and and we we have other ways
especially in the law enforcement
context to look to to verify whether
someone's telling the truth we have
there's other interview techniques I um
there's been a lot of study and work put
into those techniques over over many
years and decades in in in the law
enforcement Community but but we
wouldn't use lie detector tests in that
context and I
think you know in is in this context
where we're trying to balance the need
to to you know do some verification
investigation with with the need to
respect the fact that these are that the
these are these are victims of physical
and sexual abuse and victims who suffer
this abuse as as kids a lie detector
test just isn't isn't something that I
think would be appropriate especially
for for a process like this it really
wouldn't be appropriate in almost any
context but this is meant to be a
process where it's not litigation so
we're not we're not doing the sort of
indepth type of Discovery and
investigation that would happen in
litigation over a period of a couple
years before you got to
trial it's it's a it's a more
streamlined simpler process and the
tradeoff is that while we may not do as
much in-depth investigation and and
verification there's a cap on on the
damages you can get and you know I think
the the first Tri the first YDC trial
showed and and putting aside EV I won't
get into the details putting aside all
of the issues we litigating there post
trial about what what the damages cap
should be and how the law works on that
I mean I think you saw where where a
damages number can can be in a case like
that and I think that demonstrates the
tradeoff we we're making in this process
when you go to trial I wish you'd
emphasize to the jury where this money
is coming from with some of these
ridiculous claims it's not coming from
the actors who probably are still
collecting
pensions very few of them I think one
has been up for trial so far and I think
you got 11 people identified they all
should have been
and trial by now and been charged with
these abuses and should perhaps confront
some of
these people that they abused as Youth
and you should also make the point that
a person who worked hard all their
life and kept their nose clean and and
prepared themselves for a good career at
the end of a career might have two
million doar that they earned in their
lifetime you're giving $2 million to
people who didn't know the rules
probably didn't have a a good career and
yet they're being rewarded to some
extent for suffering which many people
have suffered without being able to get
compensated in family situations and so
on it just seems way out of line with
what these juries are reward are
rewarding and I'm wondering if you're
bringing any semblance of Truth to them
that this money is coming out of you
folks because it's coming out of the
taxes that the government collect
it's not coming out of the actors and
we're giving these huge Awards what do
they prove the lawyers get rich and the
person wastes the money and I think that
that point should be made a little more
thank you I can just assure you Mr chair
that for for the cases that do go to
trial you know we we certainly are doing
everything we can to defend them and and
I would I I feel pretty confident in
saying that I don't think we've gotten
to the extent the office has gotten
criticism for the cases that we're
litigating it is not been that we that
we haven't been pushing hard enough to
to defend them so we we if the cases go
to
trial we are thinking long and hard
about what the best way is to defend
them and the most effective way is to to
defend them and what the best argument
and presentation arguments and
presentations we can make to to a jury
are so I I can assure you of that thank
you further from the committee Mr chair
Senator gray I'm kind of uncom in some
of the things that we've said here okay
we've passed legislation and right now
we're has that legislation been
truthfully you know fulfilled in in the
documents and for us okay so again you
know we may want to do some other
changes in legislation but right now is
not the time to to do that right now we
should be looking at the document does
it fulfill the the requirements we put
in the legislation and then move
forward further questions from the
committee
members Senator
Bradley uh yes thank you um first of all
I'd like to move um both items and then
speak to them if I can motion a second
further discussion representative
Bradley Senator Bradley so um I think
kudos
to
John um all of the attorneys that are
here to the governor to our friend Karen
umberger who
sponsored House Bill 1677 this is
a very difficult
sad and awful
chapter in New Hampshire history the
trial the mean trial showed how bad the
abuse was a jury um you know found a
settlement
of a huge amount of
money
existed both pieces of
1677 worked assiduously to
protect victims because there are real
victims here victims of abuse in the
state
care and as the Attorney General's
office and attorney broadrick um and his
capable staff have um worked through the
200 cases that have been settled we've
actually learned quite a bit
and the legislation that I believe we
all voted for um certainly in the Senate
we did and I believe in the house it was
passed on a Voice vote um um also has a
responsibility to protect the long-term
Financial viability of the state so the
point that representative Lehman earlier
made um about structured settlements I
think it's important to remember that
there's a 5% interest payment for any
structured settlement is is left in the
authority of administ administrator
broadrick um
and I think the whole process has tried
to balance those issues protecting the
victims and a victim Centric
approach but at the same time the
long-term viability for the state this
is likely to be a 7 to 10 year process
at at $75 million
a um budget year in every fiscal year I
I
think this is a long-term issue that
we're trying to make the best out of a
very bad situation for doing what's
right for victims but also protecting
the state and I I think all of you
deserve a lot of credit for that um you
know the letter that John you didn't
have um in front of you that I have from
you know Russ Riley and um Dave Vin
canano um does does talk about you know
the collaboration the consensus and not
everybody got everything they wanted it
was the same thing in Senate Bill 591
but people came together because
um it just it has to be done I guess is
the best way of saying it and um so I
think it's important that those of us
that are you know that voted for the
legislation recognize this I I went
through you know the 50 or so pages of
you know the new um
guidelines it really means a lot to know
that the administrator the Attorney
General's office and you know the lead
councils have all come together on it in
the same way that 591 did so that's why
I think we should move forward approve
these guidelines um get back to you know
dealing with the at least 432 other
cases that are in front of you and
probably hopefully the vast majority of
the other ones and do your job and we
should trust the process and this is why
I know there's been questions
about you know the extent of the cost of
administering this and the point that
you Mr chairman raise is a very
appropriate one of
verification and that's why it's
important in my op opinion that attorney
brri have the necessary staff to um do
what needs to be done to a protect the
victims but also vet the testimony and I
think um so far so good it is a very
difficult situation uh one that
obviously none of us wish would have
ever happened um totally needs to be
prevented in the future and um try to
put this very sad chapter of New
Hampshire history behind us thank you Mr
chair further discussion from committee
members we have a motion and a second to
adopt the items 261 and 262 if there
being no further discussion all in favor
say I I oppose no those items are
adopted and we're moving on to thank you
thank
you uh item 11 renewable energy fund
24242 are there any any questions on
item motion by representative leishman
to approve second by Senator
dallesandro further discussion seeing
none all in favor say I I
adopted
okay do we have anything else on the
agenda that needs a vote Mr King yes you
have two late items yes uh that need
action and then one informational item
uh the first late item being
24273 request Department of Health Human
Services to accept $6 million in arpa
funds move to approve second questions
motion by Senator uh gray second by
Senator Bradley to approve the item 273
question from representative Edwards is
there someone here that can answer
Edwards I I may have spoke too too
quickly uh I'm I'm interested in the one
the new late item that has the $6
million of arpa money is this it this is
it okay so um so hi uh so my question on
this is is that we had a stablished I
think the by we I mean the the governor
and the Royal Wei from there uh the
principle that we should take onetime
money and spend it on onetime
investments and uh
my simple reading of this uh is that
we're we're taking this money and uh
augmenting sort of an operational
capability um and if that's if that's
wrong I just need to be told I'm wrong
and and and two if I'm not wrong um I'd
like to know uh if if if we're setting
ourselves up for failure because this
money won't be available uh isn't
presumed to be available in the future
budget Cycles are we are we are we
inflating the the budgets of the of our
U federally qualified Health Facilities
uh and we're not going to be able to
sustain it so those it's kind of a
conversational
question good morning Trisha Tilly I'm
the associate commissioner at the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services thank you so much for that
question representative Edwards so
you're right that has been the policy
moving forward is onetime money for
one-time events it has also been the um
the practice to use some of these arer
dollars to fill the holes for
operational losses experienced during
the covid-19 pandemic and so the
federally qualified Health Centers have
demonstrated that they have had some
operational impacts and these funds will
help fill those losses to your forward
thinking question around like okay so we
fill a bucket what happens next is a
part of these funds will will be used by
the federally qualified Health Centers
to determine a sustainability plan for
financing moving forward they um had
some uh hits in the way that the entire
Health Care System were had impacts
during the pandemic but in particular
because the fqhcs are open to all they
have um their charge is to serve the
uninsured the underinsured allc comers
who walk in the door they had a
disproportional impact they are also
having some other structural issues from
some federal um constraints around
things like 340b funding and some other
pieces and of course they've been
impacted by Staffing in the way that
every organization especially every
Healthcare organization has been
impacted so these funds will be awarded
to them on a need basis um looking at
their losses in a very similar way that
we did with the Community Mental Health
Centers which again is another one of
our safety net services so we want to be
able to have them keep their doors open
and that's that's good business for all
of us here we have to have the qhcs um
sustained uh within the state or else it
would have a catastrophic effect on our
entire Health Care system so we want to
keep the doors open we also want them
looking forward to figuring out what's
the best path um moving from this day
forward in terms of their sustainability
plans and their Finance
plans follow
up all right I so I I remain concerned
that we're spending long-term money on
operational items the the pandemic has
been over for a while and I don't know
how much longer we can uh justify trying
to repair that but but but you're
working it um my my other my other
question is is this is this U $6 million
the result of of a top down this is the
money we have let's let's put it out
there or is it the result of a Bottoms
Up needs assessment to to determine what
the what the requirement is for the $6
million which it it looks more like top
down let's spend what is available thank
you I'll take that question as well um
so we didn't propose this again this
request came directly from the federally
qualified Health Centers to gopher they
put forward a proposal they put forward
their budgets they put forward their um
financial needs and this was determined
the amount of money that was needed so I
I am sure that there was other and you
know commissioner Caswell can talk more
about that process but um they put the
federally qualified Health Centers put a
proposal forward saying these are our
needs and um we this is our plan to
address those
needs okay so I I one last one I so I
guess it's Mr casual question it just
seems to me that you all are allocating
the $6 million and it it strikes me that
we have all of these open construction
projects that are probably doing cost
overruns and I'm just I'm just wondering
if uh how confident you are that this is
the best way to allocate $6
million I am confident that by investing
in our federally qualified Health
Centers we will save money in the long
term from uncompensated care in other
System yes if there's no questions for
these
people ask Mr Caswell to come forward
this director good morning Taylor casell
representative Evers I can jump right
into your your question so this is a
this is a request that's been pending at
Gopher for several months we haven't had
the uh uh ability to put the money that
they had initially requested which I
believe is closer to 8 million do was
the total request from the health
centers um our staff working with HHS
did do uh an assessment of the need of
this program and I think um commissioner
uh Tilly spoke very well to the out
comes of that in terms of when we
determine the need uh for these
operational Investments which you are
correct we have avoided it at at great
at great um effort um but in this
instance uh it is definitely related to
covid impacts for the health centers
themselves and I think that um our my
understanding is that there are other um
accommodations on the federal side that
should be coming in the future that will
help offset these long term uh impact so
these are one-time operational impacts
that we felt were necessary to make an
investment in at this
time so so thank you for that I it looks
like Senator Bradley may have a question
but if there's no other commentary i'
I'd move the
item
oh yeah we already have a motion in a
second all right if there's no further
discussion
the question is to adopt item
24273 it's already been moved a second
we have a moveing motion in a second so
I'm just is there any further discussion
seeing none you're ready for the
question all in favor say I I oppose no
item 24273 is adopted we're moving on to
Corrections Senator leishman moves the
item is there a second is there any
further discussion
seeing none you're ready for the
question all in favor say I I oppose no
that item is
275 again went back to Mr Caswell uh
emergency relief and and governor's
office of emergency relief and and
Recovery this is telling where the
money's going and it re
reallocations uh it's quite extensive
and it's an informational item so we do
not need to have any vote are there any
questions on the
item no questions and there's no need to
to vote on that
page
and we've already planned for the next
meeting of September 13th
at 10: a.m. is there any problem with
that bdel on the informational materials
um can I still have a question from um
the
um commissioner
tourism sorry thought we were still
doing gopher sorry no um I just have a
question now um I know that uh we've
kind of been through this before um we
have the Irish um Irish New Hampshire
trade Council and in the legislation
that um they were a you were authorized
to try and do some fundraising to
support that
have you been able to do that not to
date ma'am no we don't have the
resources available for for any anything
related to that council at this point so
anyone who's assigned and going to the
caucus will not get monetary support I'm
I'm not sure I know what the what you're
refering there's a legislative caucus um
next week and there are um members that
are planning on
attending um is there any um funds
available to reimburse them for their
travels not not in my budget ma'am no
thank
you
okay uh representative wner had a
question on was it item FIS
24260 yes thank you thank you Mr
chairman I maybe Mr White could um
help me with this so this was the item
that was
withdrawn and um I just wondered if we
will see this item come before us again
and if it does will it have the same
purpose as um the item that was
withdrawn sure um so we're currently
reviewing that item uh just to make uh
just review some potential technical
changes there are no impacts to Services
I just want to make that very clear and
uh we'll determine in the the future if
we'll need to bring that back but there
are no impacts to Services I just want
to make that abundantly clear as
possible thank you of course any further
questions from the committee on
informational
items seeing none are we ready to
discuss the next meeting as I brought up
um September 13th at 10:00 a.m. any
problems with
that okay that will
will be our plan to meet on September
13th at
10:00 anything else uh Mr Kane
no I'll entertain a motion to
adjourn motion to adjourn in a second
all in favor say I oppos no we are
adjourned thank you all for your
attendance
and and for listening to all these
removals